[Musique]
reconquérir les terres fertiles et
développé tout un secteur de l'économie
locale telles sont les ambitions portées
par les agriculteurs réunionnais pour
les années à venir
marijo laine noire au fait partie de ces
acteurs du monde agricole qui souhaite
développer son activité avec un projet
innovant ce que je fais une femme
découverte avec des plantes endémiques
médicinales mais aussi avec toutes les
plantes longtemps comme le lof les bâtis
jacques manioc patates et aussi aussi
les fleurs exotiques et voit un peu de
légumes est aussi un camping et avec
tous ces produits là de transformer tout
aussi bien transformer en confiture que
les belles transformer les fleurs
exotiques en bouquets et de vendre voilà
et pour l'orienter et l'aider à
construire son projet
mario les noirs ou s'appuie sur la
cellule d'accompagnement des
agriculteurs
notre but est d'accompagner le porteur
de projet aussi bien dans le domaine
technique administratif et financier et
il faut savoir que nous suivons cet
agriculteur sur une période de trois ans
on va déterminer pour cela un phasage ce
phasage il est très important pour
orienter au mieux de l'agriculteur et
qui suivent une ligne directive
cette cellule d'accompagnement du
conseil départemental a été créé au mois
de juillet 2016 sous l'impulsion de la
présidente
l'ambition est de permettre à chaque
porteur de projet de trouver les bons
outils qui faciliteront la création de
leur activité économique
cette cellule d'accompagnement est
essentiel parce qu'elle va accompagner
de façon personnalisée les portes de
projets et donc créer de l'emploi et
développer l'économie réunionnaise donc
c'est important que l'on ait mis en
place cet outil essentiel pour le
développement agricole et aujourd'hui
tout va passer par le département qui a
le levier de développement dans la main
et qui va l'utiliser au mieux dans
l'intérêt de la population réunie
les porteurs de projets rencontrent les
conseillers au sein de permanence de
secteurs des annexes qui offre une
proximité géographique associé à un
maillage de compétences entre le
département et les communes gérons le
play et ce qui nous amène à travailler
ensemble à donner les informations
concernant l'intérêt qu'ils soient en un
clic hall ce qui est la base pour pour
approcher au niveau bac 2
après plusieurs échanges sur le terrain
est au rendez vous les porteurs de
projets comme antoine klein dispose
d'informations claires sur leurs besoins
plusieurs orientations de parcours de
développement lui sont alors proposées
par la séduit vous orienteront
l'agriculteur vers des structures
adéquates qui peuvent être
administratives techniques ou
financières et enfin l'agriculteur qui
je le rappelle est un
est un chef d'entreprise avant tout qui
et poursuivra ses démarches pour
concrétiser son projet en sachant que
nous le suivrons pour une période
minimum de trois ans peut pas
reconnaître les là où faut frapper
donc non mais c'est bien que les
parcours mais en une disposition des
techniciens pour pouvoir nous aiguiller
vers
les portes qu'il faut vingt sept
cellules répondent vraiment à un besoin
en fait oui parce que moi actuellement
on voit pas mal de jeunes qui veut aller
avant si on propose pas parce qu'il ya
tellement de débaucher peu d'accord mais
l'agriculture on voit que ça diminue
aussi en même temps donc on va poser aux
jeunes de faire de la culture bio est
prévu pour sortir de l'art grandi un peu
et avoir au moins la tête haute
la cellule d'accompagnement des
agriculteurs répondent à un besoin
d'information et d'accompagnement pour
les porteurs de projets elle est aussi
un observatoire des dispositifs en place
et des leviers nécessaires au
développement des projets agricoles
davantage d'être ça à la fois sur le
terrain ça nous permet cette proximité
de recenser les besoins des agriculteurs
mais aussi de pouvoir jauger un petit
peu les futures tendances tout cela dans
un seul but de pouvoir améliorer les
dispositifs d aide du département en
moins d'un an d'existence nous avons
accueilli émis dans une démarche de
projet environ 150 agriculteurs soient
en activité ou soit en démarrage alors
il faut savoir que pour contacter la
cellule à vous avez un numéro vert le 0
800 3 x 0 490